you must be so pleased with how the
Harry Styles thing played out well you
know my job is to meet someone audition
them look at them and and figure out
what they can do I don't think I was
that aware really of how famous Harry
was I mean my daughter had talked about
it my kids talked about him but the
truth is I cast Harry because uh he fit
the part wonderfully and truly earned
his seat at the table I think what he
does in the film is really remarkable
you know he's very very real in what he
does in the film which is what I want
it's very truthful you're playing human
Frailty you're playing an ugly side of
human nature that we all are very very
aware of in ourselves and I just felt
very kind of lucky to be involved in in
something that I thought was going to be
amazing you know it's a great thrill as
a director to see potential in somebody
who hasn't done something before
it's really fun when you get to raise
some eyebrows with a piece of casting
and people are like well what's that
going to be when you know
in your own heart I knew Harry was going
to do a fantastic job